bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire dont michael
bonjour thomas et elle a une cette
semaine je ne suis pas premier ministre
par hasard face aux critiques et face
aux couacs
jean marc ayrault lança contre offensive
le chef du gouvernement se montre plus
ferme et n'hésitent plus à recadrer est
dans sa ligne de mire le ministre de
l'éducation vincent peillon qui relance
le débat sur la dépénalisation du
cannabis en barre à gauche indignation à
droite l'ump appelle à sa démission
et puis le budget 2013 examiné à
l'assemblée l'exécutif le martèle l'un
français sur dix ne sont pas concernés
par les hausses d'impôts faux répond à
l'opposition qui dénonce un matraquage
fiscal est avec nous pour commenter
toute cette actualité pierre laurent
bonjour bonjour vous êtes de secrétaire
national du parti communiste depuis
quatre ans et depuis un petit peu moins
d'un mois autour de lui deux raisons
réelles depuis un petit peu moins d'un
mois vous êtes sénateur alors écoutez
tout d'abord quelques collègues qui vous
connaissent bien d'autres un petit peu
moins bien et puis je voudrais un petit
peu après qu'elle ait cette
acclimatation et comment vous faites au
sénat va écouter tout de suite c'est un
intellectuel c'est un ancien journaliste
il a une très grande capacité d'analysé
des situations il est très fin sur les
réflexions politiques
connaissait il a une réputation tout à
fait agréable donc il avait déjà fait
preuve de pugnacité dans les tâches les
mandats qu'il a exercée jusque là et je
suis sûr qu'il sera un
un contributeur actif au débat et
sûrement que ces propositions et
suggestions seront utiles dans nos
discussions que chacun peut trouver sa
place sans que pierre laurent qui
prennent le dessus sur la présidente je
crois pas que ça puisse ça puisse
vraiment un véritablement existé chacun
à sa place et son rôle et ce sont deux
choses complètement différentes
alors vous avez entendu alors c'est pas
facile quand même quand on est
responsable d'un parti lider patron on
arrive au sénat doit se faire un petit
peu petit comment ça se passe c'est très
facile au fait parce que j'arrive dans
un groupe qui qui était présidée par
nicole borvo cohen seat que gens que je
remplace qui aujourd'hui présidée par
eliane assassi un groupe très très
féminin et avec des fortes personnalités
une grosse capacité de travail donc ont
inséré dans ce travail collectif ont bu
je suis quelqu'un qui aime bien le
travail collectif je ne suis pas un
obsédé de la personnalisation de la vie
politique
loin de là donc moi ça me va tout à fait
ce travail collectif
c'était par la personnalisation mais
cette présidence du groupe c'est quelque
chose qui vous intéressent une ambition
que vous avez non pas du tout il était
clair quand je suis arrivé au sénat que
jeune ambitieux n'est pas de présider le
groupe auquel j'appartiens le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen et
donc on a on a désigné il y à dassa ci
et ça s'est fait à l'unanimité du groupe
tout le monde était favorable à cela
donc tout va bien
et pour porter la parole il faut quand
même quelqu'un de charismatique on dit
pas qu'il vienne l'asa ci ne l'est pas
mais vous êtes patron du parti
communiste mais bon on va additionner
nos énergies justement il y a plus pire
l'auront plus tous les autres eh bien ça
va faire justement plus de voix pour se
faire entendre tant mieux vous l'avez
entendu pour l'instant c'est un concert
de louanges sur pierre lorente on en dit
du bien de voir l'entente des dents dans
le micro trottoir à ce que l'état de
grâce sera de courte durée parler
j'espère que les
mes collègues socialistes ou écologiques
écologistes qui qui ont l'air de me
trouver des qualités écouteront les
propositions que je fais parce que il
s'agit pas seulement d'avoir des
discutions aimable on est là pour faire
des lois qui soit favorable au monde du
travail favorables le redressement de la
france
donc j'ai des propositions on a eu un
débat un peu rude sur le trait le je
suis arrivé à ce moment là sur la
ratification du traité budgétaire
européen j'attends que les autres
partenaires de la majorité se met à
écouter vraiment nos propositions alors
avoir tout ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine est évidemment en ce début de
semaine
le débat est marqué par la sphère du
cannabis il fallait faire vite très vite
même éteindre l'incendié les propos de
vincent peillon favorable à l'ouverture
de la dépénalisation du cannabis
évidemment déclenché un tollé dans
l'opposition du coup son premier
ministre jean-marc ayrault a dû monter
au créneau et rappelé aux ministres à
l'ordre les explications de betty
lachguer c'est une petite phrase qui a
mis le premier ministre en pétard
dimanche vincent peillon se prononce
pour la dépénalisation du cannabis
loin de la ligne officielle du
gouvernement je suis très étonné parfois
du côté retardataires de la france sur
un sujet qui pour moi est d'ampleur
alors on peut lutter par les moyens de
la répression je suis absolument pour
mais en même temps je vois que les
résultats sont pas très efficaces
le lendemain matin rétropédalage de
vincent peillon il parle d'une réflexion
personnelle mais trop tard la polémique
est lancée au téléphone jean marc
ayrault recadre son ministre
rue de solférino le porte parole du ps
tente de mettre un terme aux débats
matignon a affirmé ce matin il n'y aura
pas de dépénalisation du cannabis
donc ne comptait pas sur moi pour venir
en
commentant à nouveau réouvrir ce qui est
désormais clos au plus haut niveau
clore le dossier impossible pour l'ump
qui appelle le ministre à la démission
je considère qu'à partir du moment où le
ministre de l'éducation nationale peut à
titre personnel comme il dit penser
pouvoir ouvrir un débat sur un sujet
aussi grave donne une idée de son
irresponsabilité
je demande donc solennellement à
françois hollande que cette question
soit immédiatement tranché et qu'il en
tire les conséquences
à propos de la présence au gouvernement
de monsieur peillon en france la mesure
est loin d'être populaire
selon un récent sondage ifop 70% des
français se disent opposés à la
dépénalisation du cannabis
que dit le responsable du parti
communiste est ce que vincent peillon a
eu raison d'ouvrir ce débat
même s'il dit que c'est un titre
personnel d'abord bon je trouve la
déclaration de jean-françois copé sur
qui demande la démission de vincent
peillon totalement ridicule ce que je
voudrais dire d'avant je voudrais faire
une remarque préalable parce que
personne ne l'a suffisamment souligné à
mes yeux c'est comment est né ce débat
là en fait il y à une affaire où on a
révélé on a mis au jour un réseau de
blanchiment sur la drogue de blanchiment
d'argent
quelque chose qui va durer longtemps
au lieu de justement on avait l'occasion
d'ouvrir un grand débat sur comment on
lutte contre les réseaux de blanchiment
parce que ces réseaux de blanchiment met
à nu le lien étroit qui existe entre les
gros trafiquants et les milieux
financiers
et comme par hasard on a aussitôt
détourner le débat sur une autre
question et la droite s'est engouffré là
dedans pour provoquer soi-disant il y
avait péril en la demeure parce que un
ministre avait osé dire qu'il fallait
peut-être se poser des questions alors
sur maintenant sur la question mais je
fais remarquer ça parce que on a refermé
le dossier du blanchiment au passage ça
serait peut-être intéressant de se
concentrer quand même sur sa quelque
temps parce que là il ya un vrai sujet
prenant et en aucun cas d'action sur le
cannabis ont deux mots moi je crois que
le constat c'est que la loi de 70 qui
met surtout l'accent sur la répression
n'est pas efficace nous sommes en europe
un des pays où il y a le plus
au retour de consommation de cannabis
singulièrement chez les adolescents donc
nous avons un sujet qui pour moi est un
sujet de prévention et de santé publique
et la politique répressive qui est qui
est celle de la france aujourd'hui n'est
pas efficace et je crois que nous
devrions nous pencher sur cette question
et faire évoluer la législation pour la
recentrer sur une politique de
prévention et de santé publique et donc
moi je crois que la pénalisation des
jeunes consommateurs n'est pas la
solution à ce problème là et en revanche
je ne suis pas favorable à la
légalisation du cannabis puisque c'est
une question qui est posée
nous ne sommes pas favorables à sa cette
légalisation mais nous pensons que la
politique qui est actuellement sur la
table n'est pas n'est pas efficace
izagirre le disait dans son sujet 60%
des français ne sont pas pour cet ep
nisation ils vous suivent pas les
français sur ce point là mais écoutez je
je je crois que les français comme sur
beaucoup de sujets serait preneur d'un
vrai débat public sur cette question et
je crois que les gens se posent beaucoup
de questions parce qu'ils font les mêmes
constats que nous c'est à dire qu'il y à
une développement de la consommation du
cannabis 1 guillaume ans et les jeunes
ça pose des problèmes il faut les
traiter il faut les traiter
intelligemment la politique répressive
n'est pas très efficace pour faire ça
surtout qu'elle fera pas au bon endroit
c'est ce que je viens de dire sur les
réseaux de blanchiment donc il faut
revoir tout ça et moi je crois que le
pays est assez vous savez un sondage
c'est toujours un instantané si on
ouvrait un débat ouvert et qui sortirait
du débat public des idées plus
internationale passe à notre sujet c'est
l'objectif premier du gouvernement
limiter le déficit public à 3% du pib
une mesure jugée absurde par le
président de l'assemblée nationale
claude bartolone veut assouplir ce
critère en période de difficultés
économiques
il était l'invité dimanche dernier du
grand jury rtl en écoute 3% dans une
période de croissance et 3% à un moment
où l'europe est confrontée à ces
difficultés économiques que nous
connaissons ce n'est pas la même chose
et il faudra que monsieur barroso et
j'espère que le parlement européen dans
le cadre du sommet budgétaire sera lui
faire entendre ce message ce disque
c'est le moment d'avoir une autre
politique pour l'europe
alors on vous avez trouvé un allié de
poids en la personne de claude bartolone
sur ce sujet écoutez moi je fais
effectivement un constat et en
l'occurrence je le partage est ce
qu'avec ce que vient de dire claude
bartolone
c'est que on ne peut pas prendre le
problème du redressement de la france
par le bout par lequel on est on prétend
le prendre aujourd'hui il faut faire
d'abord du redressement social et
productifs et à cette condition là
peut-être qu'on arrivera et je crois que
c'est souhaitable assainir les finances
publiques mais prétendent qu'on va
parvenir à remplir cet objectif en
faisant de l'austérité de l'austérité de
l'austérité budgétaire et et qu'à
l'arrivée alors qu'il n'y a pas de
croissance on aura une amélioration des
comptes publics
on voit partout en europe que ça va
produire le contraire je crois je veux
bien prendre un exemple précis possible
qu'il amènera un exemple question par
exemple les les régions j'étais hier
dans une entreprise qui fait des trains
pour le ferroviaire une entreprise
industrielle eh bien si les commandes
des régions pour développer le transport
de fret et le transport voyageurs dans
les régions ne peuvent pas être mises en
oeuvre à cause de l'austérité dans
lequel on enfonce les collectivités
locales
l'emploi industriel dans cette
entreprise sera touchée à moyen terme
donc on voit bien qu'il y ait un lien
étroit entre soutenir l'investissement
public et soutenir le développement de
l'emploi industriel rang en un mot vous
le fait politique
vous dites que les 3% aujourd'hui c'est
inéluctable on ne les lira pas jusqu'à
ses 3 % mais non mais on ne pourra pas
l'objectif est bien sûr qu'on ne tiendra
pas l'objectif puisque nous avons une
croissance zéro officiellement depuis
trois trimestres ou sommes en stagnation
avec des gouvernements de partout
c'est ce que vous dites mais mais ils le
proclament et il est non seulement il le
proclamer haut et de surcroît il a eu
parfaitement tort de nous faire nous ne
l'avons pas fait nous d'ailleurs mais de
faire ratifier par le parlement le
traité budgétaire qui nous oblige pas
seulement à tenir cette politique
l'année prochaine mais qui nous oblige
le traité européen à la tenir dans la
durée
c'est une politique d' asphyxie au
moment au contraire il faudrait donner
de l'oxygène à l'économie
on va passer au mardi le premier
ministre tape du poing sur la table
je ne suis pas le premier ministre par
hasard voilà pour la réponse de jean
marc ayrault à la droite visiblement
touché par les critiques qui pleuvent le
premier ministre a contre attaqué lors
des séances de questions d'actu à
l'assemblée nationale pour le moins
mouvementée récit johan raud là il lui
fallait une démonstration de force
dans l'hémicycle à sa première réponse à
l'opposition standing-ovation immédiate
des députés socialistes pour jean marc
ayrault
allez moi je ne suis pas premier
ministre par hasard je suis premier
ministre parce que j'ai la confiance du
président de la république et de la
majorité majorité gouvernement main dans
la main n'est ce pas toutes être les
porteurs d'une opposition bien décidé à
saisir sa chance
après une longue série de prises de
paroles contradictoires au sommet de
l'état il ne se passe pas un jour sans
qu'un dirigeant du ps ou pire un de vos
ministres ne vous défie est ce qu'il y à
encore oui ou non un pilote dans l'avion
car quelques heures plus tôt à la radio
jean marc ayrault a bel et bien dû
rendre des arbitrages sur tous les
dossiers qui fâchent du moment message
de fermeté ou aveu de faiblesse
pas question groupe ps de parler de
crise d'autorité l'autorité du premier
ministre
elle n'est jamais mise en cause
simplement ce n'est pas une autorité qui
empêche la discussion sa majorité ce
qu'il y a nécessité à écouter en dernier
ressort ce qui est l'avis du premier
ministre ce qui est la position du
gouvernement
touché par l'un de ces arbitrages le
rapporteur ps du budget auteur de la
proposition controversée sur les oeuvres
d'art défendre a bel et bien son
amendement tout en saluant l'esprit de
dialogue du chef de la majorité il prend
le temps d'écouter les parlementaires
s'il ne l'avait pas fait sur cette
question pas sur ces questions parce
qu'il y en a plusieurs
je pense qu'on aurait une vraie
situation de crispation jean marc
ayrault est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
loyal par rapport au président de la
république mais aussi très respectueux
des parlementaires socialistes dans la
tourmente les députés socialistes
promettent de ne pas être godillots face
au gouvernement
mais en cas de désaccord les débats se
feront peut-être plus feutrée pour ne
pas émoussé davantage l'image d'un
premier ministre
chahuté pour son manque d'autorité alors
vous l'avez vu dans ce reportage un
premier ministre attaquer attaquer à
tort ou à raison qu alors en mai par la
droite à tort et moi je crois qu'il faut
arrêter de se laisser impressionner par
la droite qui est vent debout
depuis le printemps dernier qui n'a pas
digéré sa défaite et qui veut faire quoi
en fait
obliger le gouvernement à rester dans
les clous de la politique qui a été
suivie depuis dix ans et qui reçoit pour
ça l'appui du medef parce qu'on voit
bien que la voix de la droite et du
medef sont convergentes en la matière
donc il faut arrêter de se laisser
impressionner par ça et il est
parfaitement normal qu'il y ait un débat
dans la gauche et moi je compte le
porter comme parlementaire parce que
pour sortir le pays de la crise il faut
qu'il y ait une confrontation loyale à
gauche sur les sosies de nokia lors de
la confrontation on peut le rappeler
quand même vous n'êtes pas dans la
majorité gouvernementale n'a pas de
ministre ce qui vous empêche pas d'être
au sein d'une large majorité de gauche
mais vous êtes aussi quand même très
très critique avec ce gouvernement met
donc vous êtes dans une forme
d'opposition câble avant nous avons
voulu nommer les choses sont très
claires il ya une opposition de droite
et d'extrême droite
nous n'avons rien à voir avec cette
opposition là et pour nous il n'est pas
question d'alimenter ce type de
critiques surtout qu'on sait qu'elles
sont faites pour revenir à la politique
antérieure qui a échoué
en revanche il y a effectivement dans
ceux qui ont voulu le changement au
printemps dernier donc nous faisons
partie de ceux là puisque nous avons
contribué à battre nicolas sarkozy ce
très content télégramme
non c'est pas une position compliquée
nous voulons que le débat se développe
parmi ceux qui ont voulu le changement
sur les solutions à apporter et quand
des solutions ouvernement talent ne nous
paraissent pas adaptés à la situation
nous le disons et nous avons voulu nous
savions que ce débat allait avoir lieu
nous le savions c'est pour ça que nous
avons décidé de ne pas aller au
gouvernement parce que le centre de
gravité qui était retenu par le
président de nous paraissait pas à la
hauteur du problème
donc ça nous a pas fait basculer dans
l'opposition mais nous allons porter nos
solutions sur le budget mais sur la
forme qu'on voit l'histoire du cannabis
l'histoire des 3 %
est-ce que j'embarquais aujourd'hui il
un problème d'autorité il a du mal à
discipliner un petit peu les
parlementaires mais aussi des ministres
mais on va pas résoudre les problèmes de
la france par la discipline la droite a
fonctionné comme ça pendant cinq ans il
y avait un chef et un sol nicolas
sarkozy et toulon devaient rentrer dans
l'euro et pas seulement les
parlementaires mais le pays parce que
quand il y avait la majorité du pays
dans la rue
contre la réforme des retraites on
disait de toute façon on va rien changer
ça c'est pas une manière de gouverner un
pays où des popularités pouvait
expliquer par ça justement non non ils
reprennent la semaine à jo popularité
des sondages n'a rien à voir avec le
problème d'une soi-disant cacophonie il
a à voir avec une contradiction de fond
qui existe c'est que le gouvernement à
des contradictions de faux quand il dit
je veux réorienter l'europe très bien
mais il y en même temps il faut ratifié
le traité budgétaire qu'on voulu nicolas
sarkozy angela merkel contradictions ça
ne peut pas marcher
quand il y les plans sociaux sont
inacceptables très bien mais ils les
laissent s'appliquer en a un et il ne
veut pas augmenter congénères qui rend
la loi d'interdiction
il ya un problème jean marc ayrault mais
non mais ça n'est pas un problème de
personne ça n'est pas le problème ce
n'est pas le problème jean marc ayrault
jean marc ayrault et le porteur de la
politique qui est celle du parti
socialiste et du président de la
république et on en mettrait un autre
qui porterait la même politique dont il
n'a passé de la peau des choix
politiques dont il faut discuter un
problème sur la fin on va parler du fond
cherche 30 milliards désespérément c'est
le leitmotiv du gouvernement le projet
de loi de finances le fameux budget 2013
est actuellement débattu à l'assemblée
entre la majorité et l'opposition la
guerre est déclarée reportage une rolls
à betty la guerre et pierre lascars le
débat budgétaire nouvelle tribune de
l'opposition à l'unisson araud à l'ump à
lui d ea sur la mouture 2013 de la loi
de finances
objet de quelques cafouillages entre le
gouvernement et sa majorité
ce soit sur la redevance télévisée sur
sur l' isf sur tous les sujets qui vont
être débattues le ministre et les
ministres concernés une position le
premier ministre en a une autre et donc
chaque jour il ya un couac
supplémentaires ce budget il est
caractérisé par un manque de courage
parce qu'il n'ya aucune réforme
structurelle qui nous permettent
d'espérer des lendemains meilleurs
l'opposition votera contre le front de
gauche pourrait quant à lui s'abstenir
même reproche d'incohérences trop de
reculades dit-on en matière de justice
fiscale
nous ce que l'on pensé qu'un cap doit
être pris il doit être tenu dans l'eau
qu'à se laisser se laisser berner par
que
par des campagnes qui sont conduites en
particulier par le medef
attaqué sur tous les fronts le groupe ps
organise sa défense
qu'on se le dise les arbitrages rendus
par le premier ministre seront suivis à
la lettre
il est normal que les parlementaires
veulent y jouer leur rôle parce que
c'est au parlement ce fait la loi
il est normal aussi que le gouvernement
veuille une cohérence de sa politique
par rapport à ses engagements et une
fois que le dialogue ait eu lieu un
arbitrage seront et nous appliquons cet
arbitrage cet après midi les membres du
groupe majoritaire se sont donné rendez
vous pour discuter de leur
fonctionnement interne une réunion de
crise pour trouver la meilleure façon
d'épauler un gouvernement malmené dans
les derniers sondages
après l'assemblée ce texte va être
examiné au sénat pierre laurent après
tout ce que vous avez dit depuis le
début de l'émission vous ne pouvez
sûrement pas voté pour ce texte est ce
que vous allez voter contre le budget
en l'état nous ne pouvons pas voter pour
dre nous allons nous battre nous allons
donc nous allons nous battre dans le
débat parlementaire en faisant des
propositions alternatives et nous
déciderons de notre vote en fonction de
ce qui sera retenue ou non nos
propositions
donc nous voulons nous engager
effectivement dans une dans une bataille
dans le pays est dans une bataille
parlementaire pour réorienter le budget
parce que d'un côté on a des mesures de
justice sociale un peu nouvelle et nous
sommes favorables à ces mesures même si
elles nous paraissent insuffisantes
parce que la grande réforme fiscale
qu'on nous avait annoncé la grande
réforme de justice fiscale n'est pas au
rendez vous mais il ya des mesures
fiscales mais le problème c'est qu'elles
sont gâchées parce que au lieu d'être
mises au service et recettes un peu
nouvelle au service d'une politique
d'investissements publics
elles ne servent qu'à rembourser de la
dette et et on accompagne des politiques
d'austérité va gâcher
s'il reste en l'état le budget vous
voter contre aujourd'hui on discutera ou
s'abstenir ont voté contre en fonction
du résultat des vies celui ci n'ont pas
gardé grand show de vos amendements si
j'écoutais ça c'est vous qui le dites
veut nous quand on entre les mains mais
parce qu'on l'a écouté le parlementaire
socialiste vous que vous interrogiez
dans le reportage dit c'est au parlement
que se fait la loi
moi je parte achats c'est au parlement
que se fait la loi et ce qui vaut les
parlementaires socialistes veulent faire
entendre leur opinion bas nous aussi du
rêve ou quoi
au sénat il ya une majorité dans
laquelle nous comptons notre groupe est
nécessaire à la majorité donc nous
allons faire des propositions que les
combattre l'opposition phare si vous
deviez n'en retenir qu'une qui pourrait
être acceptée par la gauche et qui vous
permettrait de voter ce texte et par
exemple il faut créer une tranche
d'impôt supplémentaire
je rappelle que cris à 45% pour le
relais 150000 euros de revenus aller
plus loin pourrais je rappelle que les
sénateurs communistes et les sénateurs
socialistes ont voté il y un an à
l'automne quand le sénat a basculé à
gauche
un projet de finances rectificative et
les socialistes avaient voté avec nous
dans ce projet il y à une proposition de
tranches sur l'impôt à 50% pour les
revenus supérieurs à 380 mille euros eh
bien nous allons reproposer cette
tranche la et puisque les socialistes
ont voté un an
il faut il ya un an il faudra qu'ils
nous expliquent n'accepte pas qu'elle
serait pas possible de le voter
aujourd'hui et nous avons sur ce point
là mais sur d'autres sujets beaucoup de
propositions
mardi toujours le ministre de
l'intérieur devant les sénateurs pour un
portrait de la menace terroriste une
menace venant de plus en plus de
l'intérieur le projet de loi qui a
présenté permettra de poursuivre les
français qui commettent des actes de
terrorisme à l'étranger ou qui partent
s'entraîner au jihad toutes les
explications et d'abord on va écouter
manuel valls ces individus véritable
ennemi de l'intérieur reprennent une
menace diffuse qui demande donc un
travail de surveillance lourd et
méticuleux la france a déjà été frappée
dans sa chair par le terrorisme elle
connaît l'enjeu et le prix de la lutte
qu'il implique
mais la france n'habitera jamais face
aux menaces
le pays est confronté à un terrorisme en
constante mutation
alors pourquoi est ce que les
communistes n'ont pas voté ce texte
alors qu'il paraît presque consensuel et
partent normal parce que on nous
disposons aujourd'hui surtout qui a déjà
beaucoup
un de ce type qui ont été votées nous
disposons aujourd'hui d'un arsenal
suffisants pour mener la lutte dont
parle manuel valls et que maintenant à
force d'en rajouter d'en rajouter on à
laurie d'une mise en cause d'un certain
nombre de libertés publiques
donc ça ne nous paraît pas nécessaire
par exemple le suivi très précis des
individus en question
on sait très bien on l'a vu dans la
ferme ra que ce sont des gens qui sont
connus des services de police qui ont
même été parfois entendu qu'ils sont
repérés donc ce travail là nous avons
les outils aujourd'hui pour mener ce
travail nécessaire et de vigilance
contre des actes terroristes
donc c'est qu'il serait inutile et il
s'agit là encore oui et il s'agit là
encore est même dangereuse d'une certain
point de vue parce que on continue dans
une veine qui a été développé sous la
droite en l'occurrence et qui rit et qui
est il vise encore un vice qui vise en
fait à faire croire qu'en se donnant ses
outils de mise sous surveillance des
libertés publiques supplémentaires c'est
comme ça qu'on va lutter contre le
terrorisme alors qu'en vérité
on commence à prendre des risques de
plus en plus important avec ses libertés
on passe au mercredi l'assassinât de
l'avocat d' yvan colonna relance le
débat sur la sécurité en corse son nom
antoine sollacaro tué de 9 bat l'ajax au
c'est le quinzième homicides depuis le
début de l'année une situation
insupportable a jugé jean marc ayrault
le premier ministre le gouvernement se
veut à l'offensive sur ce sujet on
écoute jean marc ayrault
cette situation est insupportable
le gouvernement est déterminé à agir
avec la plus grande fermeté la plus
grande détermination contre ce fléau qui
mine la corse qui est le crime organisé
depuis de longues années
alors on va vous interroger sur le fond
de cette affaire évidemment dans un
instant mais je vous propose d'écouter
juste avant le témoignage d'un de vos
collègues sénateurs
vous connaissez c'est jean pierre
chevènement ancien ministre de
l'intérieur
spécialiste de la question corse écouté
m c'est le chaos
n'était pas seulement une figure du
barreau unanimement salué pour son
talent c'était une figure de la
dépendance isme un militant nationaliste
engagé y compris dans des actions
clandestines
je n'en dirai pas davantage pour ne pas
manquer à ma déontologie d'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur voilà pour le
témoignage de l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur que vous venez d'entendre
d'abord sur le fond sur la corse un
statut pénal spécifique pour la corse
vous trouvez ça juste normal ou est-ce
que la corse et la france et qu'il faut
faire comme partout d'ailleurs pas de
statut spécifiques et d'ailleurs
le président de l'assemblée de corse mon
ami dominique bucchini s'est prononcé
clairement contre cette idée il s'agit
d'appliquer en corse le droit et la loi
comme partout il y a un travail qui est
mené à l'assemblée de corse où
l'impulsion de dominique bucchini et des
des élus et qui a identifié des causes
de la dérive actuelle nous avons des
phénomènes de spéculation immobilière en
corse extrêmement préoccupant et dont on
sait qu'ils ont des liens avec les
réseaux mafieux et les réseaux du bon
ski s il peut jean pierre chevènement et
on ne fait rien contre ces mécanismes de
spéculation immobilière il y a un
travail engagé autour du plan
d'aménagement et de développement de la
corse le pas du pur justement maîtriser
ces phénomènes c'est cela qu'il faut
soutenir
il y a un problème de d'imbrication des
réseaux j'en parlais tout à l'heure des
réseaux de blanchiment ça c'est rsa
serait très intéressant d'aller regarder
de près dans ce qui se passe encore ces
cétacés phénomène de fond qu'il faut
s'intéresser fait rien pour vous dire
pour mettre à nu ce qui conduit à la
dérive actuelle qui est inacceptable dit
à laurent ne fait rien je le disais en
titre 15 homicides depuis le début
l'année 37 en deux ans est ce que le
pouvoir politique aujourd'hui que ce
soit de droite de gauche et impuissant
face au politique peut faire des choses
mais à condition de s'attaquer à la
racine de ces problèmes que je viens
d'évoquer
et pas seulement de faire des effets
d'annoncé comme si on allait résoudre le
problème avec des quelques effets
d'annoncés en termes de moyens policiers
ou autre il faut mettre des moyens mais
des moyens qu'ils soient attachés à ces
problèmes de fond là la spéculation
immobilière dans l'île la présence de
réseau de réseaux mafieux et de réseaux
de blanchiment qui travaillent et qui
s'infiltrent de plus en plus dans l'île
et qui entraîne une dérive violente
absolument préoccupante
mercredi en conseil des ministres le
gouvernement a présenté un projet de loi
sur la banque publique d'investissement
objectif de cette bpi financer les
petites et les moyennes entreprises et
c'est jean-pierre jouer quand prendra la
présidence toutes les explications
d'elisa berthelot mais une banque
réservés au financement des petites et
moyennes entreprises
une promesse de françois hollande
présenté ce mercredi en conseil des
ministres 40 milliards d'euros de budget
et une mission soutenir les entreprises
et leur permettre d'accéder au crédit
pour se développer localement ou à
l'international en plus
d'investissements ce sera un outil de
croissance offensif au service des pme
dès pme industrielles des établissements
de taille intermédiaire c'est la banque
des petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est la banque de l'industrie c'est
l'investisseur de long terme dont nous
entreprises de croissance ont besoin
plusieurs entités seront regroupés au
sein de la bpi la banque oseo une
filiale de la caisse des dépôts et le
fonds stratégique d'investissement en
faveur des pme la banque sera cogéré par
l'état
la cdc et les régions jean pierre jouyet
directeur de la caisse des dépôts la
présidera les investisseurs attendent
maintenant que la bpi fasse ses preuves
cette banque va peut être aider à
coordonner tout ça est un mieux
dispatcher les crédits ce qui est
important c'est qu'elles agissent
vraiment dans les régions en accord avec
les projets de développement région le
dispositif devrait être opérationnel à
la fin de l'année mais la création de la
bpi suscite déjà de nombreuses questions
notamment sur les risques
d'instrumentalisation politique ou
encore sur ses capacités de financement
inférieure à la demande annuelle des pme
et tpe
jean-louis borloo a commenté cette
semaine cette affaire de la vie
payer en parlant de nouvelles affaires
de crédit lyonnais c'est la banque
qu'elle fait faillite on se souvient
après avoir investi dans des mauvais
projet est ce que selon vous la belle
épine la bpi démarre là ce que elle est
condamnée à la faillite cette banque
non pas du tout il sait pas ça la
question nous avons un urgent besoin de
doutes doter d'instruments public
bancaire et financier pour piloter le
développement économique et financer le
développement industriel la transition
écologique du pays donc nous avons
besoin d'instruments public
le problème de la bpi c'est que c'est un
instrument pour le moment qui est tout
petit par rapport à ce que nous à ce
dont nous avons besoin premièrement donc
nous nous proposons quelque chose de
beaucoup plus large qui serait un
secteur bancaire public et financier
très important et pas seulement une
petite baie pays telle qu'elle nous est
trop petite elle n'a pas les moyens
suffisants on va à l'essai on laisse
aller à l'écart l'essentiel du secteur
bancaire il faudra nous expliquer
pourquoi pourquoi on laisse 1000
milliards dans les mains des banques
pendant qu'on va en avoir 50 avec la bpi
on pourrait quand même se doter vu le
problème qui nous est posée avec le
niveau de chômage d'outils plus
important que ça deuxièmement il ya un
problème de deux critères de crédit
comment on va utiliser l'argent en
question
nous nous faisons une proposition c'est
que le critère il doit devenir sélectif
maintenant si c'est pour financer des
projets créateurs d'emplois des projets
qui répondent à des normes sociales
environnementales on bonifie les crédits
voir on fait des crédits à très bas taux
voire à taux nul si c'est nécessaire
mais si c'est pour financer pour
accompagner des projets qui visent
uniquement à accroître la rentabilité
des entreprises contre l'emploi alors là
où on fait du crédit dissuasif position
c'est quelque chose que vous allez
mettre sur la table bientôt oui ça fait
7 et nous allons nous battre dans les
régions puisque les régions vont être
impliqués dans la bpi nous allons nous
battre dans les régions sur les critères
de sélectivité d'utilisation des crédits
de la bpi elle va changer de sujet et on
retourne au scénario ce mercredi sans
jeu de mots il ya de l'électricité dans
l'air au scénario vous en êtes aussi
pour quelque chose vous le groupe
communiste la cause c'est bien sur ce
texte sur la clarification progresse
de l'énergie les communistes je le
disais s'y opposent
on fait le point avec jérôme rabier le
débat sur la tarification progressive de
l'énergie provoque des étincelles au
sénat en cause un bonus malus en
fonction du niveau de consommation des
ménages jusqu'à un certain seuil
le tarif est subventionnée au delà c'est
le malus est le tarif est relevé une
disposition qui casse le principe d'un
tarif unique sur tout le territoire pour
le groupe communiste sur la
progressivité de la tarification
d'abord je pense qu en l'état c'est
inattaquable
donc effectivement il ya tout à revoir
dans la sérénité ce qui n'est pas le cas
ce matin les communistes demandent donc
l'irrecevabilité du texte et un autre
front s'ouvre sur la droite de la
majorité les élus centristes et ump ont
quitté la commission des affaires
économiques ce matin pour protester
contre la méthode adoptée
on n'a jamais vu cela le président de la
commission nous a tout simplement
proposé de commencer à étudier la fin du
texte et de repousser
l'étude de la première partie du texte
qui est en même temps le plus important
c'est à dire les tarifs progressifs le
bonus malus la chaîne prochaine un coup
politique préparée selon la gauche qui
fait valoir que le texte aborde aussi
d'autres dispositifs comme les tarifs
sociaux et la trêve hivernale il y a en
france plus de 4 millions de personnes
qui sont en situation de précarité
énergétique
on peut considérer que on peut faire des
coups politiques ou comme nous nous
pensons qu'il ya urgence d'agir de faire
adopter des dispositions pour protéger
ces gens l'ensemble sera rediscuté la
semaine prochaine en commission avant
son arrivée dans l'hémicycle le 30
octobre
si la droite les centristes et les
communistes maintiennent leur position
le texte déjà voté par l'assemblée
nationale risque d'être rejetée au sénat
alors jérôme rabier l'expliqué dans son
sujet c'est vrai que c'est un fait
rarissime
l'ump le centre les communistes contre 1
ce texte c'est une alliance presque
inimaginable pour des raisons très
différentes pour des raisons très
différentes et il faut bien comprendre
que d'abord il ya un aspect d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que au sénat le
gouvernement est en difficulté ce texte
il est ni fait ni à faire
il a été on n'a pas fait d'études
d'impact on a pensé n'importe comment
les choses ça a été adopté très
rapidement sans vraiment de préparation
à l'assemblée nationale et on s'aperçoit
que ce texte
progrès situation a changé aussi donc le
texte pose beaucoup de problèmes
le minimum sur un sujet aussi important
serait de prendre le temps c'est pour ça
que nous proposons l'irrecevabilité pour
qu'on puisse travailler et travailler
dans la sérénité
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
deuxièmement nous ce que nous mettons en
cause c'est que le tarif unique qui
permet une péréquation permet un droit
d'accès de tout le monde
et s'il y avait des choses à faire
évoluer ce serait avec des tarifs
sociaux mais pas avec une modulation qui
est prévue aujourd'hui uniquement sur
des critères de consommation et qui ne
sont pas adaptés à la situation actuelle
j'entendais le sénateur socialiste qui
pointe justement et à juste titre le
problème de la précarité énergétique
mais par exemple au risque de pénaliser
avec ce texte d des gens qui vivent dans
des dans des immeubles ou dans des dans
des maisons très mal isolé et on sait
qu'elles sont très nombreuses dans le
pays et de les pénaliser soi disant pour
les inciter à moins consommer mais la
conséquence concrète de ça c'est que ces
gens vont se priver de chauffer
correctement il faudrait un autre chose
c'est-à-dire un vrai plan avec beaucoup
de moyens pour mettre aux normes brice
lefaux bien laurent que voulait remanié
cette proposition de loi mais le ps
apparemment ne l'acceptera pas vos
amendements là est ce qu'il ya c'est ce
que vous irez jusqu'au bout de ce combat
là aussi écouter à force nommé revend la
désormais très mais à force mais vous
verrez vous verrez que la vie nous
donnera raison parce que les nous nous
appuyons quand nous faisons des
propositions sénat nous ne sommes pas
dans une guérilla parlementaire nous
nous nous appuyons sur des problèmes qui
nous sont posées par le pays par les
interlocuteurs sociaux syndicaux que
nous rencontrons nous sommes en dialogue
avec ses forces sociales et le problème
que nous posons est un problème qui est
posé par de nombreuses organisations
syndicales en l'occurrence et par de
nombreuses associations de consommateurs
donc je pense que au bout d'un moment
peut-être que c'est pas le cas encore
suffisamment aujourd'hui c'est certain
mais je pense que non parlement et nono
nos partenaires de la majorité vont
devoir entendre ça et s'ils ne le font
pas c'est eux qui vont être dans la
difficulté et venir vers vous enverra un
petit peu plus tard va passer au jeudi
quand françois hollande parle de la
responsabilité de l'état
le 17 octobre 1961 des algériens qui
manifestaient à paris étaient tués lors
d'une répression sanglant des dehors
d'une manifestation
la république reconnaît avec lucidité
les faits les mots sont précis sont ceux
de françois hollande les réactions à
cette annonce avec marie brémond
quelques lignes pour reconnaître un
drame celui du 17 octobre 1961 journée
meurtrière a paris une manifestation
pacifique d'algériens et réprimé dans le
sang avec l'aval du préfet de police de
l'époque maurice papon
le bilan est lourd des centaines de
morts selon certains historiens 51 ans
après je crois que il était temps que le
président la république intervienne
aussi fortement aussi symboliquement
aussi franchement aussi pour cette
reconnaissance très forte du chef de
l'état pour dire les fautes de la france
un communiqué l'elysée pour reconnaître
les fautes de la france mais certains
veulent tally plus loin dans la
reconnaissance les sénateurs communistes
souhaitent qu'une journée soit consacrée
aux victimes de ce mardi noir
il faut que ce soit une journée
une journée de souvenir c'est pas
forcément pour culpabiliser ou être
passéiste c'est juste que voilà il faut
ça fait partie de la mémoire de notre
histoire mais les réactions politiques
ne sont pas unanimes à droite on dénonce
la repentance outrancière moi j'en ai
assez que tous les quinze jours
la france se découvre une nouvelle
responsabilité mettent en avant sa
culpabilité permanente on est déjà dans
un pays qui est en dépression nerveuse
quasi permanente
on n'a pas besoin de ça au delà de la
vérité historique il ya un contexte
actuel françois hollande doit se rendre
en algérie en décembre prochain
ce que n'a pas manqué de souligner la
presse algérienne qui y voit un signe
fort ou un petit geste avant une visite
compliqué à l'elysée visiblement on
prépare le terrain alors le sénat
étudiera une proposition de résolution
qui émane de votre groupe ce sera mardi
prochain la parole de françois hollande
est ce qu'elle est allée assez long
c'est un geste extrêmement important et
nous l'apprécions comme tel nous nous
battons depuis des années pour la
reconnaissance officielle du crime de du
17 octobre 61 parce que je rappelle
quand même qu'il ya eu ce soir là dont
paris onze mille arrestations
les historiens s'accordent aujourd'hui
sur le fait qu'il y a eu au moins 200
morts
des algériens jetés dans la seine
retrouver dans des dans des forêts aux
limites de paris donc un drame horrible
qui n'a jamais été reconnu et dont on
sait bien l'artisan était le pouvoir de
l'époque assez loin
je crois qu'il faut encore aller un peu
plus loin et je le dirai dans
l'intervention je ferai au sénat mardi
il faut notamment une chose très
importante déclassifier les archives il
faut rendre accessibles les archives de
la police
singulièrement de l'époque pour qu'on y
voie clair sur les responsabilités de
sera seul à mardi de ce drame a été
reconnu il faut que son caractère de
crime d'état soient établies et
l'ouverture des archives peut y
contribuer vous avez entendu françois
fillon est ce que au final c'est aux
politiques s'occuper de l'histoire non
mais il s'agit pas de s'occuper
l'histoire là il s'agit de la
responsabilité de l'état ce crime a été
ordonnée à l'époque au plus haut niveau
et
conduits par le préfet de police de
paris qui n'était pas n'importe qui
puisque c'était maurice papon
donc l'état doit le gouvernement doit
reconnaître que là le pouvoir de
l'époque le pouvoir politique de
l'époque a malheureusement joué un rôle
sinistre dans cette dans cette affaire
et ensuite il doit permettre aux
historiens de travail et c'est pour ça
que je demande l'ouverture des archives
vous défendrez cela mardi au sénat au
passé un autre sujet c'est désormais
officiel harlem désir et le nouveau
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
les militants l'ont désigné avec 72 5%
des voix très loin du plébiscite
attendu pour le candidat officiel de
l'elysée de matignon ou encore de la rue
de solférino et la révélation c'est une
autre personne c'est emmanuel maurel
avec 27 5% des votes c'est lui et lui il
incarne la gauche du parti
il a su tirer son épingle du jeu durant
ce scrutin est ce que vous avez plus de
points communs car laurent avec emmanuel
maurel qu'avec harlem désir
oui je crois qu'au plan des positions
politiques j'ai plus de points communs
avec emmanuel maurel que je connais par
ailleurs il est vice président de la
région ile de france et c'est vrai qu'il
ya des points notamment de critiques du
du pacte budgétaire ou sur d'autres
questions nous nous nous retrouvons je
pense que ce vote est intéressant dans
la mesure où il montre qui a
effectivement au sein même du parti
socialiste
un débat sur les orientations
gouvernementales actuelles
et quand harlem désir ben je lui dis bon
courage il ya du boulot parce qu'il faut
un sacré coup de braquer à gauche du
parti socialiste
et s'il peut le conduire je lui souhaite
du courage en tout cas nous on va
l'aider à ramener le ps vraiment dans
les rails de lagunage un compte facebook
je voudrais quand même terminé cette
émission pour vous montrer avec cette
image image du parisien magazine celle
de arnaud montebourg en marinière sur
fond bleu et rouge prenant le made in
france
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
image
écoutez bon je sais pas comment on en
est arrivé à cette image mais j'ai envie
de dire que peut-être que depuis avec ce
qui s'est passé cet été ce qui se passe
tous les jours il faut arrêter avec les
coups de com et les coups de pub ce
qu'attendent les salariés du pays c'est
maintenant des mesures législatives
forte
c'est une action politique de l'état
pour relancer une politique industrielle
dynamique est bon le made in france est
plutôt crédible vous y croyez pas ce
made in france il veut des rayons de
supermarchés dans les supermarchés ryoma
d'efforts qui est des rayons il faut
produire et le problème actuellement
c'est qu'on ne s'occupe pas de protéger
on ne s'occupe pas comme il faut de
protéger notre outil pour de notre outil
national
donc il faut arrêter de fermer des
usines parce qu'on peut toujours faire
des rayons mais si on continue de fermer
les usines au rythme on le fait
aujourd'hui les rayons uv l'action de ce
ministre du redressement productif on
parle beaucoup de lui
c'est un bon ministre mais écoutez il
essaye de se battre en tout cas ils
essayent de se battre visiblement il va
rencontrer les salariés c'est déjà pas
si mal par rapport à ce qui se faisait
avant qu'un dialogue avec eux mais pour
le moment en tout cas je ne sais pas si
c'est lui ou si c'est le gouvernement ou
si c'est les pressions du medef
mais pour le moment il n'obtient pas les
moyens d'une politique de redressement
productif suffisant et là nous nous
allons prendre des initiatives pour ça
moi j'étais dans le nord pas de calais
hier
nous allons en novembre prendre une
initiative nationale je prononcera un
discours sur cette question du
redressement productif national et nous
voulons lancer une bataille dans la
durée aux côtés des salariés pour
essayer d'engager cette politique là
c'est beaucoup car laurent d'avoir été
l'invité de parlement hebdo cette
semaine merci thomas et nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine le week
end à tous alors